Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center every person who
prays in this Masjid every child that
memorized the Quran you will inshallah
share in that reward donate now guys and
do not delay
Ed brothers and sisters and dear friends
before I start I want to praise Allah
the most merciful the most trust or
Praises glory and gratitude belong to
him as you guys might know that or you
may know not know but a brother that I
differ with and I've made videos about
it as well
um made a video about a tick tocker this
brother called Riyad whatever his name
is I don't really know I don't really
care what his name is really it doesn't
really matter but what's important is
for us to warn against such deviant
misguided individuals now before you
guys jump to assumptions accusations
we're going to God and not only that I'm
going to invite him he's actually
waiting here I'm going to invite him and
we're just going to dissect this matter
one by one and expose is reality x was
what kind of a person this person really
is and how he is using his Tick Tock
dawa to misguide the people so I'm gonna
invite him here yeah so there is
so let's get straight into it bro um
obviously I don't know if you heard well
I just said maybe you might find it
funny I don't find it funny with the
smoke from your face uh but let me put
it like this yeah
um we know what you're trying to do yeah
you can find it funny we know what
you're trying to do
um and I personally believe from the
statements that you've made I believe
that don't take it personally but I
believe you're misguided even individual
your deviant person reason why number
one let's let me ask you questions yeah
the first thing you said that
is understood as that hukum is only for
Allah which of the salaf understood this
who understood this like that the way
you put in it
all of them
give me one give me one name
ah you can't okay let me move on let me
we're going to carry an explosion we're
going to carry me exposing you you said
that for example when it comes to the
issue of Khalifa yes we know your HD his
word you know probably you're connected
to them
um and I'm not gonna call you it's not
my I'm not qualified to do that you know
but there's some stuff that you've said
which they've said so you know I'm not
gonna say you are but I'm gonna leave it
at that you know if you're repeating the
same metric they're repeating and you
know you're talking about khalafa and
hukum is only for Allah I mean somebody
watching that I don't know what else
they can think but you know again I'm
not seeing your hawari let's make the
clay it's not I'm not qualified to do
this you know I mean what do you have to
say for yourself you know you're clearly
misguided you're a deviant I mean please
explain yourself I mean if people are
watching this by the way please explain
yourself yeah go on
so yeah what you just did is basically
what what's surgery
you've got nothing to say just say
I say you want to evidence okay
for the guy I mean you call him a
deviant you're calling them you know
misguided you know you're throwing these
words you know you're taking things out
of context and I would have to agree
with you I would have to agree that what
I just did here was unjust why did he
was taking things out of context on top
of that to call him misguided in the
Deviant it's a boat thing it's a big
claim now the point here is that these
are not the things I'm actually saying
but Maria knows this this is what was
said to you by Brother Sajid yeah so
this was a little because people
watching this are going to find what I
just did this distasteful they're going
to be watching and thinking you're not
letting the guy speak you'll keep quiet
Etc you know
and even though Sajid done it in with a
you know calm Melody like calm tone the
point is this the accusation is still
there so the reason I did it in this
manner is because it doesn't matter if
it's done in a soft tone or if it's done
harshly the accusation the slander
trying to insinuate that a brother who's
given dawa is somehow connected if we
was talking about an issue here
pertaining to whatever it may be like a
rape case and then I somehow inserted
your name and even if I said oh it's got
nothing to do with you well let's just
you're gonna think why are you even
mentioning that
so I'm Gonna Leave the fruit to you bro
and I hope I didn't really hurt your
feelings that was a little uh think
about it but real tell me firstly I came
across some of your videos and I know
you do some dawa with the brothers uh
from Shepherd's Bush they do Darwin
Shepherd's bush I know I know these
brothers yeah so the thing is there's
some accusations that were thrown to you
by sergeant and I'll put it I've said
this before a lot of people might think
my issue with Sajid is personal yeah and
I believe it's not I generally saw him
as a brother and there was things that
you know happened he did this to
um brother Esq from New York he did that
to Jake yeah talking about that like the
continuity argument when we not even
Tamia uses a form of a potential he said
it's allowed to use it then he did it to
Abdullah and Lucy then he did it to
myself then he did it to hijab I see a
pattern and this is always what I've
been talking about you know I don't want
Brothers in the tower fighting each
other unless if somebody's calling for
outright misguidance of course they need
to be critiqued and advice in in person
however as I I'm not gonna say
prophesize but I knew this was coming
now you are on The Hit List you are the
next person now from the videos I
watched of you bro you're a compound
individual soft toned I haven't seen
anything that gives me alarm Bells so
can you break down to us what is the
problem that Sajid has after all of us
with you
I think the first thing I want to say
bro is Mela forgive him may Allah
forgive this brother because subhanallah
I mean whether he's sincere or not is
not a thing that I'm going to argue
right now what I'm going to argue is
that this brother is a Muslim and Allah
has given him a platform and instead of
using this platform to essentially speak
about the things that matter most he
starts pointing fingers at other Muslim
YouTubers tick tockers whatever it is
and makes videos about them and what he
doesn't realize bro is that there is
a little bit of lack of wisdom here
right and he's up like you said and with
this whole skit you know you've kind of
basically shown that he's claimed I'm a
deviant that I'm misguided has he said
this by the way
just to be clear has he called you a
misguided misguided deviant okay look so
if I was to summarize this video what he
said was I'm not gonna I'm not claiming
this guy is deviant but he's a deviant
that's how that's the tone that came
across from the video I'm sure you saw
it I'm sure a lot will will agree with
me outside the video has he called you
this
um
and it was it was insinuated but I can't
remember if he said it directly but the
point is bro okay that me bro I make
videos online right and I'd say probably
like 20 to 30 of my followers are
non-muslims right so now I'm in a
position now where someone has come out
he's spoken out against me he's claimed
I'm a deviant without allowing me to
basically have a conversation with him
properly hearts are hot
and subhanallah bro now I'm in a
position where people are kind of
Shifting away from me and I also have a
followership of people who shouldn't
really
like see this side you see what I'm
saying so now now I have to create a
response and tread on eggshells bro to
make sure that actually this isn't what
Islam is but also to get my point across
that I'm I'm not preaching these
ideologies right so I mean whether he's
sincere or not male or forgive him bro
honestly may Allah forgive him what a
question we're not question is sincerity
somebody can be sincere and do things
which oppressed others like the prophets
Allah said
um help your brother he's if he's the
oppresso the oppressor and they said we
know how to oppressible how do you have
the oppressed by stopping suppression
and that's the reason I'm doing this
video bro because at the end of the day
I've done this before with prophet and
brother
do I doubt their sincerity not really
but they have oppressed people I have
had nothing personal with them the same
thing goes with sergeant if he's going
to carry on attacking people which he
has which he has Muslim and now you're
on the line and I know it's not going to
stop and if it doesn't stop it's he
exposes himself and if he does stop it's
good for me if he stops at least he's
not attacking Dua if he doesn't stop at
least now he's building a reputation of
who he really is and what he's trying to
do so you said you trying to have a
private discussion with them which I did
as well and I tried my best to reconcile
he wasn't having none of it bro so that
again it's just I don't know what he's
going what's going through his mind so
what happened after
the discussion
well yeah you wouldn't have a private
discussion Etc he didn't want to do and
he does this a lot I've said to him come
let's have a public discussion he always
shies away to me as if seems as if
someone above him is giving him
protocols do ABCD and he's just
following that because why would you
have a discussion why don't we just come
and have a discussion on me and you and
talk okay this is what he meant this is
where I was coming from let's understand
each other he doesn't want to know so
it's very bizarre and then he goes and
does these videos and he accuses you
yeah one of the things he's you had to
indirectly think is that you like are
you connected to his brother no are you
sure about that the issue yeah 100 bro
and like
sorry are you sure no no no no look the
thing is bro look this is what I really
wish for my Muslim brother Sajid and his
likes as well bro that just please be be
aware that Allah says in the Quran
Allah has revealed to you a book in it
our clear foundational verses which
there are no two ways interpreting them
and then you have verses which are
ambiguous that Allah has opened
interpretation for them now we as
Muslims bro we defend the truth we don't
defend our egos we don't defend our
teachers teachings we don't defend our
seniors we we strive for the truth
wherever it may be this is what a Muslim
should do and when it comes to matters
like this instead of looking to your
teachers and looking at what they taught
you about these different groups and
then trying to match these two things
together so like you for example the
hero Brothers say ABC and that matches
the rhetoric of ABC that you learn from
your teacher instead of trying put to
put them together just be aware of this
verse right and just ask questions try
and hear the person's side of the story
perhaps there's something new you could
learn don't put your teacher on like the
Holy Grail of knowledge yeah and make
make him out to be like the the knowing
everything right and just listen to the
other side and when I was speaking to
him about it he wasn't listening bro
before he made that video he wasn't
listening he was just categorizing
categorizing categorizing deviant
deviant deviant HD HDH that's all he
said exactly that's all I want just
listen and we'll all learn from each
other right and perhaps we'll achieve
what Allah says
hold firmly to the Rope of Allah do not
be divided this is what Allah wants
they see they say that we can only we
can to unite we have to disunite these
are the things that you hear so you see
a pattern bro and I've seen this because
I've dealt with the lights off Sajid
I've dealt with him yeah Sajid is just
more of the same thing sadly of a Karma
tone so he's more of a look
methodology very clear I've made it very
clear yeah I I don't follow I don't
believe that we should rebel against the
rules I believe it brings more harm than
good yeah
okay so the the My my what I'm on is
clear okay but what I see and what I
I've seen this bro I have never seen
anyone any group of people I'm not I'm
not trying to generalize I know there's
very good Brothers among the salafi
communities as well yeah like I'm one of
them like I'm not saying I'm one of the
good Brothers I'm saying like I I cross
myself as a following the methodology
but bro Allah not the not the rafita not
the Braves not the asharis not the
matter it is not us none of them has
slandered me cause me harm or anyone in
the Thousand as much as their super
selfies none of them bro I'm telling you
and the question is I'm in bro 99.9 of
our manhaj is the same and you thinking
bro they even attack each other because
you have like different levels you have
you know the really hot and then you
have the lemon and herb and the mild
they have different categories okay so
they attack each other and they even
sometimes unjust bro when I saw that
video that was sent to me and I was
thinking how could you labor or even
think just because look there's some
characters yeah like the president said
they would recite the Quran but they
will never understand it will not go
down their throat they are known to have
marks on the head of prayer I can't go
to a brother and see him and the man
should come in and saying oh we want the
rulership to be for Allah okay it's got
Mark of prayer and then I see another
trait of him and then I go oh this one
it must be what kind of what how can you
be to escape write something to someone
just because they utter some statements
and that's exactly what he was doing in
the video like putting my differences
aside looking at it like if I believed
he was calling from his class I even
spoke to you before we did this yeah I
asked you some simple questions and I
was like oh my gosh like how much
more can you be unjust because do you
like you don't believe that there should
be Rebellion against the world I found
that mistaken yeah
no so I what I believe bro is we follow
the prophetic methods
in the prophet Muhammad is the perfect
example and the prophet Allah built the
people bro he started with the people
but he also worked at the top so I don't
believe that we should overthrow
governments uh with the state of the
ummah that we have today no so yeah so
the the thing is like what I would say
is that at the end of the day like which
you the video that you've done about
them
like one understanding was a video about
um the the canoe King yes such Doesn't
mention this at all in the video he
takes one thing you say and this is okay
this is he's taking a statement you're
taking saying out of context what was
that video about actually so people
actually know about watching this yeah I
mentioned this in my response which I'm
sure you'll mention at the end link to
it you can see the full response
inshallah
um but bro the video was basically a
Muslim politician pledging allegiance of
obedience to King Charles
so I addressed from the angle of
obedience from the angle of sovereignty
because of the context now what this uh
brother surgeon did may Allah forgive
him is that he left the context out he
took that statement matched it to what
he's learned about it
it's an injustice it's an injustice but
may Allah forgive him honestly because
again sometimes we say something smaller
we know from you say something small or
in the eyes of Allah it's something big
and I promise you bro I promise you
whether online whether in DMS whether in
person I'm feeling the effect of what
he's done now people are genuinely
concerned people are genuinely confused
and he's caused me quite a few problems
and a lot of headache um but this this
reason I'm doing this video bro because
anytime someone doesn't just like I said
before I've done this before so no one
come and say are you in this because you
have something personal no but then that
one was attacking people
we've got a whole SP files dedicated to
it anytime somebody oppresses another
believer unjustly I believe defending
the honor of a Believer it's a duty of
everyone not just me if you see an
injustice happening you have to so to me
when I saw that look do I want the whole
company for only Allah yes to come back
yes all day every day I don't care if
you call me call me whatever you like so
it's so prophetic that for one can you
imagine you just want the hook of the
people Allah you should love such a
person if they are going to the ideology
of like no we should overflow government
unless well that's a different story
let's try to understand the problem
let's give him doubt but to go and
describe just because a certain
statement is said here and there and
then to ascribe it and make something
but that's not it exists is a big
so that's why I'm doing this video so
people can know that you do dawa yeah
your Dao style is different because
brother started he just he usually sits
at home and he reacts to stuff and these
days now he's just all he's doing is
just nitpicking and bro that video
you've got so much content like some
Tick Tock and stuff like that yeah to go
and find that bro you must be looking
for it it can't be oh I was just
scrolling brother Ria's video and he
said something and I was like whoa bro
you it's as if you were going to find it
like okay where can I find it and that's
the issue I had with him and that's
what's interesting about that point bro
is that through this content through
searching for this content I say the
opposite of what he's claiming as well
which this is why I find it really
bizarre I mean there's videos that I
have which go against his con his his
claim that he made in his so why leave
those up you know why go out of your way
to use someone who does have a platform
and handling may Allah accept it and
then use that to create a narrative at
the expense of this person's you could
say reputation whatever you want to call
it just to spread a certain uh any
agendas
there you go they're basically going and
looking and trying this as if like you
know when somebody goes and tries to
plant something like let me prompt it
here so this looks like that yeah that's
that's what's happening here because why
else would you do it your video in
general you do dawa you do face to come
videos you you involved in dawa like but
outside his style is that yeah and I've
seen a video of him where Christian
tries to approach him for I don't know
if it was a confrontation but he
absolutely walks away why I understand
I'm not going to blame him that's his
style of dawah he he doesn't deal with
you know
conversing confrontation that's not his
style maybe maybe he's not
um well well versed in it we can't blame
him I can't have a go at him and be like
oh why I understand that's your style of
tower you know
um but the point is this it's just a
nitpick and like I said before bro it's
anyone that's watching this you can
clearly see a pattern happening and
those brother side just stops it's good
stop attacking stop attacking people for
no perfect reason it's perfecting now if
you want to carry on that's fine
whichever one you want to do is good if
you stop attacking the world what happen
we don't need to attack it if you carry
on that's also good because now people
can see your true face but you are all
you're doing is nitpicking bro all
you're doing the stuff that is attacking
for hijab for doing an interview with a
transgender can they not receive that
one Jake for using continuous argument
which even tell me who's the form of it
yeah yeah you attack excuse for some
other reason me cause I was cringing a
video no problem I was a cringe I
accepted so all your videos are Petty if
it was something where we said some
blasphemy if we said something which is
need correction we'll understand but all
you see is petty things and it's as if
he's waiting for it bro and anytime you
or me or hijab or sq or anyone is trying
to reach out to him privately and be
like bro let's not do that because the
bigger picture it affects the Muslims
people don't want to see it and but what
I find funny is that the people fail to
realize that there's one person
attacking multiple people but then
they're coming to you and saying Oh but
you guys should not have this fit now
hello there's one person attacking
multiple people
in person against him he did the same
thing Prophet again he's our brother
attacking multiple people so when people
come to me like what's your beef with
this person I call brother this person
has a beef with 20 other people you're
telling me what's my beef with them I'll
have a beef with him he has the beef
with 20 other people so International
that's what it is and is there any
anything else you would like to clarify
for the people because alhamdulillah
like I said before you don't believe
certain stuff you don't describe to HD
yeah uh you don't say you do yeah like
at the end there are brothers as well
yes I differ with them in you know in a
mythological perspective there's some
things really there's look there's
things that you can take from everyone
yeah and now they're gonna me saying
this by the way I'm a Juani straight
away now me saying you can take
something from everyone
do you see how they would take this and
be like ah this is
so anything that you say bro you're
finished I mean I don't really care
about I know myself something myself
inside outside some say I'm a salafi
outside everyone inside yes
I know what I'm doing in Charlottesville
Allah that's all I care about and if
there's any last words you would like to
see for the viewers who are watching
this
um and we can just wrap up in Charlotte
they can go and watch a full video of
clarification
I appreciate you giving me this platform
as well I just want to remind myself
first and foremost bro about anything
that I put out because of the algorithms
of today reach everyone bro you're
reaching all sorts of backgrounds you're
reaching Muslims you're reaching
non-muslims you're reaching islamophobes
you're reaching people who are
interested in Islam and when you are
putting stuff like this out you have to
think what you're doing you have to
think of the consequences I've already
had multiple comments on my video saying
this is what the Muslims are about
Muslim versus Muslim we Liberals are
we've proven that our ideology is better
that is this is an injustice group and
subhanallah Allah says in the Quran
called to Allah using
with with good manner so this is just
one reminder for myself so just think
before we upload the videos like this
and inshaallah may Allah accept and
forgive us all and guide us all
inshallah exactly you know and to be
honest if I wanted to use their tactics
I could easily find traits in Sajid and
be like this is I could easily say that
no hikama always attacking the Believers
I mean one thing the Hawaiians were
known for they're they're deep hatred
towards Muslims and their love for the
the enemies of Islam I can make this I'm
not going to go down that route you know
and even like for example um I think
again you see brought the double
standards and the Injustice like he done
a video once I think saying that uh
Basics International what I remember is
that he's basically trying to insinuate
that there is nothing like you know I do
my dawa so he's saying basically there
is nothing good about me something along
those lines how Injustice well at least
what life is my enemy if he's doing that
one he's calling to Islam well I'll say
there's good in the guy let him carry on
and
um well why let me tell you something
bro this is very very important yeah I
know he'll probably do a video to this
here wallahi there is some there was a
video that came about came out about you
know I don't know if you know yeah it's
not just friend yeah okay well why this
video wouldn't finish him off
I'm telling you this video that came out
Aki you know what we did when we saw
that video we didn't say yes
no who said you know he's our brother we
all make mistakes let's turn a blind eye
let's turn a blind eye
did I did I go I could have broke I
could have made that video go viral
hundreds and thousands of views yeah and
Sajid they would never do a video
attacking each other when it comes to
each other they use the Hawaiian
principles you support differences aside
do you ever see Sergeant the [ __ ]
ships
no they don't you know why because
they're like ah we got bigger enemy they
put things to a side we just why don't
you apply the same thing many people
started knows he's done videos with
they've got some views where I'm like
bro why are you not going to do a few to
them what their opponent is worse than
like what I did my cringe video but the
excited you see the double standards and
hypocrisy of our salafi sadly some
however salafi brothers and that's all I
would have to say bro well we hit that
video of Abu Muslim he knows if he's
watching this he knows exactly what I'm
talking about we hid it why because
we're not opportunistic we don't look
for okay how can I can you imagine me
living and being like how can I catch
out my fellow brother in the tower
defending Islam how can
what a disease of the heart that you are
looking for someone and there's Hadith
for the person from the mistaken that if
someone looks for the fault of the
believer Allah will find his fault in
his house he'll be exposed in his four
walls Allah will expose you so we ask
about Sajid once again to please stop
attacking Duart please stop it one lie
people are starting to see if you stop
it is good if you carry on we ask Allah
to expose your reality simple as that
and that's all I have to say brother's
full video of his explanations of the
things that he was accused of falsely is
out there and he's made his position
clear he's not the Hawaii it's not
connected HD he doesn't ask for
Rebellion against he was talking to
before only Allah I want the same yeah
I want the same and the Hadith that he
uses about 30 years of Raja and then
Dynasty that very same Hadith says at
the end that they will return back to
arashe's Khalifa and started to say oh
no I'm fixing bro you're a Martinez Too
watch this video inshallah and I hope
that's clarified I'm here and whoever he
attacks unjustly I'm here if anyone's
watching this you've been attacked by
Manchester I am here to have my platform
to defend yourself
that's it so next time brother sisters
yeah you can follow Barbara on Tick Tock
he does some good reminder this is good
videos I will some of them he's not
perfect I'm not perfect and um if it was
perfect you know we'll be Angels but
anyways may Allah bless you guys until
next time
slow
yeah I'll pause you know
it's not life I'm gonna probably
um
yeah I'm probably gonna
Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center if you don't need to
build this machine Allah build a house
for you in Jannah with bricks of gold
and silver every person who prays in
this Masjid every child that memorized
the Quran you will inshallah share in
that reward doing it now guys and do not
delay